The solutions to this absolute value equation are 1 half, or 3. If you got the
right answers, great job. Let's see how we got these answers. This time, I have
an absolute value equation, but I have an extra term next to the absolute value.
Before I can split my absolute value equation into two cases, I have to isolate
the aboslute value first. So I can do that by subtracting. 2 from both sides.
Then, I have the absolute value of 4 x minus 7 equals 5. Now that my absolute
value is isolated, I can split it into two cases. I have 4 x minus 7 equals 5,
and 4 x minus 7 equals negative 5. So, let's solve this one first. I add 7 to
both sides, 4 x equals 12. I divide both sides by 4, and I get x equals 3. For
the negative case, when I add 7 to both sides, I get 4 x equals 2. When I divide
both sides by 4, I get x equals 2 4th. Remember, whenever I have a fraction, I
have to make sure I put it in lowest terms or in reduced form. So, 2 4th is the
same as 1 half. And that's how we got 3 and 1 half. Let's try just a couple more
absolute value equation problems.